hi
everyone welcome to the document ai
session
i'm siddhirawanguri and i lead the
document ai product suite at google
cloud
a quick run-through of the agenda today
i'll be starting with the challenges and
market opportunities we're seeing
in document processing and dive into a
product overview of document ai
i'll also be sharing some customer use
cases and some exciting new
announcements in document ai solutions
following that my colleague obviously
will unbundle some of the technologies
we use under the
let's dive right in
nearly all business processes today
begin
include or end with a document
most companies are sitting on a document
goldmine
think pdfs emails customer feedback
patents contracts technical documents
sensitive documents hr files and the
list goes on
and these documents are only going to
grow with time
if you're already trying to make sense
of your documents it's likely you're
only scratching the surface
a lot of these documents are
unstructured
which can be very time consuming to
process
now what do we mean by structured and
unstructured
twenty percent of enterprise data is
structured
now by structured data this can be human
generated or machine
generated data that is highly organized
and formatted to be searchable
a lot of data analytics tools out there
can be used to process structured data
however 80 of enterprise data today
is still unstructured this unstructured
data
is in the form of freeform text such as
written documents
emails comments and the data analytics
tools
out there to process this unstructured
data are still very nascent
document processing has become
increasingly complex with time
processes that involve large volumes of
unstructured content are increasing day
by day
for instance top tier logistic firms
process
over 50 000 bills of ladings per day
the diversity of incoming data spans a
variety of doctypes and formats
for instance the average mortgage
application today exceeds
over 350 pages and over 60
major document types
why is the diversity increasing this
diversity
can be increasing because of government
regulations
and as the types of business
relationships
and entity linkages across various old
documents increase with time
a lot of external knowledge can also be
associated with a document in its
evaluation process
for instance looking at a document you
may need to know if
this driver's license is the official
nebraska driver's license format or not
cross-linking entities within various
incoming data streams
generates major new value and analyzing
the semantic
depth of documents can unlock
various insights within businesses
however processing these documents is
quite challenging
because of the various document formats
the manual processes
the costs of error a lot of bad data and
long processing times
and delays businesses are faced with
high costs
lost revenue and missed opportunities
that's where document ai comes in
in a nutshell document ai
extracts structured data from
unstructured content
document ai enables businesses to unlock
insights from your documents
with machine learning this can enable
businesses to
make better decisions such as analyzing
customer feedback
processing invoices or reduce mortgage
processing lines
document ai can both extract as well as
classify
informations from unstructured documents
now document ai within google cloud
builds on top
of our computer vision natural language
and knowledge graph technologies
we have a variety of products within
google cloud
ai to make customers where they are
within document ai building blocks we
have a suite of
products under general document ai
custom document ai
and specialized document
by general document ai i'm referring to
ju google's general ocr models
applied to your content custom document
ai
enables you to train custom models on
your content
to identify domain specific content
tuned to your own specific training data
with specialized document ai you can use
google's turnkey models to get out of
the box
extraction and classification for some
of the most common document types in the
world
let me unbundle that for you a little
bit more
with general document ai we have we have
our
print ocr and handwriting ocr apis
that are already in ga and
they support over 200 languages with our
print ocr
and over 50 languages with a handwriting
ocr
these are already available under the
vision api today
recently we've also introduced the form
burster api in beta
and this enables you to identify spatial
content
such as key value pairs tabular content
within highly structured forms
with custom document ai last year
we went out ga with automl dock
classification
and automl dock extraction invoice
these tools enable you to provide your
own training data
and tune domain specific content
extraction and classification applied to
your
own business documents we're also
introducing
custom form parser apis in alpha
that can enable you to extract content
provided a single blank form template
with our specialized document ai suite
our
goal is to catalog and build dedicated
models for some of the world's
most common document types these
document
models are highly accurate enabling you
to classify and identify specific
document types such as invoices and
receipts
and various other document types that i
will be talking about shortly
you can also provide data validation
and knowledge graph validation against
dates addresses and various entity types
that you find within these documents
and with this turnkey capability you can
apply these models to do classification
and extraction
against your own documents a high volume
documents that you find within your
business processes
some examples of our specialized
document ai models are
the invoice parser apis and the receive
parser apis which are now
available in private beta
across various industries such as retail
financial services healthcare media and
entertainment and
industrial we are seeing customers use
document ais in ways we couldn't have
imagined
for instance in retail document ai is
being applied by our customers to
analyze
customer feedback and process store
manager feedback to optimize the supply
chain and build better products for
customers
our financial services customers are
using document ai to cut mortgage
processing types
and analyze volumes of different
document types that are typical to a
loan origination process
within healthcare claims document ai is
applied
to cut critical timelines and analyze
claims much faster
media and entertainment companies are
using document ai
to build recommendation engines and
analyze
comments and build various feedback
systems
within industrial use cases
document ai is used to analyze highly
technical manuals and site assessment
documents and in some cases analyze
archives of documents that are over 100
years old
one company that has reimagined their
document strategy by leveraging document
ai
is the industry leading market services
provider mr cooper
they are challenged to manage many
domain specific mortgage document types
and have classified over 100 million
pages
they have trained over 130 mortgage
document labels and
achieved over 92 accuracy in
classifications
using document ai they trust that their
content
can be accurately classified
another company that has leveraged
document ai specifically a custom
document ai suite for classification and
extraction
is docusign docusign has strained
millions of document types using our
document
custom document ai models and have been
able to build an accurate auto tagging
system that can enable their customers
to autofill some of the key
fields that are highlighted in in yellow
on the screen
here's an example of a tagged w9 form
that has been prototyped using document
ai
document ai can also be applied to
various insurance claims use cases
a large us-based insurance provider has
been able to leverage document ai
to achieve over 74 reduction in claim
processing
and insurance settlement time the
accuracy of our models
has been over 81
another large us-based financial
services company
has been able to achieve over 97.8
accuracy using document ai
to analyze over 350 documents per minute
with that we are very excited to release
some new
updates to document ai today
mortgage packages have historically been
a very
complex and document intensive workflow
in our economy
now these packages packages can be an
ideal use case for document ai
why mortgage packages are
of very high volume they're a mix of
structured semi-structured and
unstructured content
there's a lot of content validation
requirements on these mortgage packages
and the same mortgage package is
analyzed over and over again within
origination securitization
and servicing and sometimes multiple
business units within the same financial
institution
process income and asset documents
multiple times
leading to a lot of inefficiencies once
the mortgage packet is converted into
structured
data it can be fed into multiple
downstream analytical and operational
workflows
we at google have identified with our
partners and customers
various mortgage document types that fit
into a typical origination workflow
and bucketed into various
high-value use cases
one of our first focus areas is the
income and asset
document bucket i'm excited to introduce
the lending document ai
solution this is a bundle of specialized
models
focused on document types used in
mortgage lending
in a nutshell using lending document ai
a loan package can be converted into
structured data
by applying a specialized dock ai models
built for
various income and asset document types
such as w2s
tax forms bank statements and pay stubs
i am also excited to introduce a second
document ai solution
called procure to pay document ai
document ai for procured a helps
enterprises
automate one of their highest volume and
highest value business processes
the procurement cycle we provide a group
of ai powered parsers starting with
invoices and receipts
that take documents in a variety of
formats and return
cleanly structured data
earlier this year we used the power of
document ai
to help in response to proven 19. we
developed the ppp lending ai solution to
help
lenders accelerate and automate
processing loan applications for the
paycheck protection program
the document aipbb parser api made it
possible for lenders
to handle the large intake volumes of
ppp loan requests
by using ai to extract information from
their loan documents
submitted by applicants
here are some of the key document types
supported by our ppb commercial lending
document ai
document ai is also used to bring
normalization to id and
password documents
with that i'd love to hand over to my
colleague lewis slew to talk about some
technologies we use under the hood
thank you sujra now let's see document
ai
in action with a demo first we will try
to parse it inways
the image you saw on the left there are
a lot of
content in it you could see multiple
addresses
different dates and many other details
in the tabular format
then we will make this even harder
it is a camera capture image of a w-2
form
and it's wine stained and image slightly
screwed
and a lot of paper folds
first we upload this invoice to the
invoice password
within seconds you can see the extracted
entity
nicely mapped to a well-defined schema
this is very powerful because you don't
have to maintain
any rule-based mapping layer or any
post-processing
scripts and this also make
value normalization to be possible
within the same ui you could also
inspect
and review the key value pair and table
extraction results
these outputs are handy and useful if
you need to apply
additional processing or data mining
having seen this on the ui now
let's run our w-2 form through the
command line
this is how production systems integrate
with document ai
this is a the highly distorted w2 form
we saw earlier
what we're going to do is we send this
image
through our landing dock ai endpoint
and load the output into a bigquery
table as a data sync
with speed query you could perform more
advanced data analytics
or just like us simply look at the data
in a tabular format
if we compare the result side by side
we actually extract values from the form
with
high accuracy and confidence
let's take a look at few of them
ssn social security number
all nine digits match the document
even though hyphens are in the original
field
employer identification number is also
correct
and the more challenging case the
employer name
and address on row number six
the entire cell also extracted 100
correct
getting data extracted from these two
documents
is no easy task let me show you one of
the state of arts model we have built at
google
unlike classic nlp tasks document like
invoices do not contain natural language
as you might found
in regular sentences and paragraphs
data here is often represented in tables
in addition many documents have multiple
pages
varying numbers of sections and have a
variety of
layouts and formatting clues to organize
those
informations an understanding of
two-dimensional layout of the text on
the page
is the key to understanding such
documents
earlier this year we published a new
state of arts research
paper on extracting data from templatic
documents this technique is combined
with many things we learned
and used from building optimal natural
language
entity extraction models to better
understand receipts
bills insurance quotes and etc
if you're interested in learning more on
this topic
i encourage you to take a look at this
paper
many of our customers asked about what's
coming for doc ai
let me now give you a sneak peek into
the new document ai portal
it's a one stop shop where you can
create
view and manage everything needed
to solve your own business document
challenges
this also includes a new processor
library
a gallery of specialized passwords
such as invoice passer 941 form password
or www passer apart from the specialized
ones
the library will also host other tools
like
ocr and forum password to help you
better understand your documents
introducing another new feature in
document ai
human review an integrated experience
to give you full confidence on accuracy
and accountability of the model helping
you meet your regulatory and compliance
requirements as well
taking a deeper look at the human review
configuration panel
you will be able to choose different
validation methods
and labeler options if you already have
an
in-house workforce or are using an
existing
bpo or are completely new
to human review in your ai ml workflow
we have an option for you we are very
excited
to see what you will be building with
our new doc ai interface
and with that i'm handing this back to
cedira
thank you lewis to wrap up if you think
you have a great use case for document
ai
i'd like to encourage you to identify
and prioritize
workflows that will benefit the most
here are
here are a few key resources you can
find out
more on our website or reach out to our
partners
who are familiar with our technologies
to such a custom solution for your needs
we hope you are as excited as
we are to apply document ai to your
business today
thank you